[Applause]
[Music]
I am confident in this team I am
confident yep whether the Republicans
take the House of Representatives or not
because the Democrats have controlled
the Senate they will be in a negotiating
position where they'll be able to
advance much of the president's agenda
so this is a huge victory for President
Biden and for the Democrats
turn our Southern border
this is also somewhat of a referendum on
Donald Trump and there's a very powerful
signal that a lot of Voters even in
Republican leading states are illides
with Donald Trump and his endorsed
candidates
[Music]
incredibly
turnout and I think it's a reflection of
a quality of our candidates and the
they're all running on the same program
so I feel good I'm looking forward to
the next couple years
[Music]
if Republicans control the House of
Representatives President Biden will
have to negotiate with the Republicans
it's certainly going to be a challenge
but if it's a narrow Republican majority
then that's going to be easier than if
it's a big Republican majority
[Music]
foreign